we've reported this year on allegations
of sexual harassment against powerful
people from Hollywood to Capitol Hill to
the media but a new investigation by the
New York Times gives voice to people in
blue-collar jobs the article explores
decades of sexual misconduct allegations
at two Ford auto plants in Chicago the
day that really sent me over the edge I
was loading a robot and he walked into
the same cell that I meant and grabs my
behind I turned around to him and I said
keep your hands to yourself
as I've told you plenty of times before
I'm not interested CBS News contributor
Jody Kanter is a New York Times reporter
her colleagues broke the story about
harassment at Ford after talking to more
than 100 current and former employees
and industry experts
she has reported extensively on several
harassment allegations including those
against Harvey Weinstein geordie Jody
joins us once again at the table and
Jody have to say you you caught my eye a
couple days ago with this tweet if
you've read our stories about harassment
among the famous and elite please
promise me you'll also read this
shattering tale set on Ford factory
Fords and shattering is a word what
these women endured please give us a
sense of what these what these women put
up with for years this is some of the
most flagrant behavior we've heard about
in all of our investigation this year my
colleague Susan Shira and Katrin Einhorn
spoke to many women who from the very
first day of work encountered harassment
freshmeat was yelled out as they entered
the factory almost a signal of what to
come
they were groped they were propositioned
and work was used as leverage one woman
basically had to sleep with her
supervisor she says in order to get the
timetable she needed to make a daycare
arrangements no they were offered five
dollars for oral sex and told you should
take that as a compliment one woman's
called peanut butter legs what does that
mean because it's the color of your legs
the kind of legs you like to spread I
just thought this was so egregious and
so despicable but what these women put
up with one woman was bitten on the
I mean and also the other significant
thing about these findings is that they
stretch across 25 years and what we've
tried to do in our reporting this year
is not only talk about the harassment
but talk about the systems that enable
it and part of what's really striking
about this case is that the Union
basically failed to address these
complaints the Union became very divided
in its mission because it seemed
according to the women more concerned
with protecting male workers who were
accused of harassment than really taking
up the women's cause and the EEOC got
involved that's the federal agency that
is supposed to combat sexual harassment
Ford knew what was happening instituted
new training that faded away so as we
head into 2018 what I think we're all
thinking about is how do we actually
change the American workplace are we
gonna be sitting here this time next
year having the exact same conversations
or is there some sort of path forward as
you talked about sorry the institutions
that are around this we have heard from
Ford's CEO Jim Hackett who issued a
letter to employees yesterday saying it
was gut wrenching
to read the New York Times and saying
this there is absolutely no room for
harassment at Ford Motor Company there
will be no retaliation against anyone
who speaks up what was there about
prevention prevention and also
accountability right that was a very
powerful letter from the CEO that was
Ford strongest signal to date many of
these women including the woman you
showed at the beginning Suzette had
talked about how for years she wanted an
apology from Ford well she finally got a
powerful one yesterday in the form of
this letter that was sent to all
employees what we do not know however is
what the accountability is for this
happening because the sad truth that
many people feel is that unless somebody
can be fired for sexual harassment or
fee serious jobs consequences nothing
really changes the United Automobile
Workers Union Jodie which is one of the
most powerful unions in the country
still has said it has a zero-tolerance
policy for sexual harassment but as you
point out in the article they're obliged
to protect both the accuser and the
accused and in
this case one of the union officials who
was supposed to be helping the women was
actually accused of sexual harassment
himself I love that Ford's response as
they view their harassment as episodic
not systemic I was very surprised based
on what you all laid out in this article
that that was a response yes and and and
the situation inside the factory is that
Susan and Catherine reported was more
complicated there were people who tried
to help the women there were men who
stood up for the women so it's not that
it was a one-dimensional portrait but
what they came away with was this
stubborn and pervasive sense that this
was the culture at these factories and
that it was incredibly hard to change
such an important article that you did
and I love the women saying you know
there's been so much about me too and
they're saying what about us and you all
certainly address that it is a must-read
Jodi it is a must-read yeah thank you so
much Jodi thank you